we've all wished to become that guy who
takes on a group of baddies and kicks
their butts without breaking a sweat or
other times we just root for The
Underdogs that will sacrifice their life
to protect those they care about with
all the odds stacked against them these
are the moments that make us cheer gasp
and Marvel at the amazing animation and
storytelling of our favorite anime in
this video we'll be talking about the
best one-man Army moments in anime
released from 2020 to 2023. First up we
have the living meat blender vampire
from our favorite evil protagonist anime
Overlord
[Music]
shouts is genocide of the kwankwaso as
I'd like to call them the cave furries
is a one-sided Slaughter of over 50 000
with even women and children not being
spared from the might of the blood
Valkyrie Killing start with aura sealing
off the poor quagwas to prevent any of
them from escaping the leader of the
Demi humans then Witnesses the two floor
guardians of nazari Gloom over them as
they give the people an ultimatum keep
in mind here that there are over 60 000
quagwas and that only ten thousand would
be spared the leader of the furry's
watches in horror as tens of his
soldiers die from each of shelter swings
being trapped in an unknown Dimension
courtesy of Aura he's left with no
choice but to comply ordering his troops
to select 2 000 from their children and
kill the rest animation is nothing to be
proud of just a casual madhouse style of
using CGI in large fights but the
Ragdoll of the furries caught up in
shaltier's attack kind of sells the
power behind those strikes
thank you
next is striga fighting in day armor
Castlevania season 4 has been nothing
short of awesome and whilst there's more
to it than the fights and action
sequences it's moments like these that
truly send it over the top Feast your
eyes on this eye-popping sequence of
striga just destroying everyone inside
it's as brutal and violent as you'd
expect and I don't think Maximum Carnage
would be enough to describe the
destruction she released on everyone the
action's fluid the choreography is on
point and you could really feel the
impact every time she swings that large
sword of hers an awesome moment as one
of the audience a truly harrowing moment
though if you imagine yourself in that
scene
the Lord of Decay is coming up next
in the entirety of the mha Universe I
think it's fair to assume that
shigaraki's Quirk Decay is one of the
most destructive and dangerous quirks
out there this is due to its ability to
senselessly destroy everything it comes
into contact with from inanimate objects
to biological life you can't escape its
Advance if it sets its eyes on you on
the day of its Awakening a single
contact from his Quirk easily turned
xlist into a lifeless statue only for
him to crumble away afterwards a single
activation of his Quirk even managed to
envelope a huge chunk of the city with
his Decay rotting and crumbling away
everything may it be the people or the
buildings it doesn't care who it affects
for it only has one objective and that's
to redistribute you into the soil
full-on senseless Slaughter and
destruction a perfect Quirk for the
series main antagonist
[Music]
we'll be popping heads this time because
coming up next we have makima from
chainsaw
[Music]
if we're talking about one-man armies
one thing you should take into
consideration is the fear and effort one
displays when they're taking on multiple
opponents because enemies should feel
the inevitability of death and defeat
and in this scene it's a master class
when it comes to those two categories in
makima's counter-offensive against the
would-be terrorist attempts to
kidnapping denji retreated to one of the
most gruesome and awesome scenes in
anime bodies get crushed when the
inevitability of death slowly creeps up
on the gang members with no one to shoot
at no one to yell at and no one to
bargain with you just wait for your turn
to dice as simple as that makima wasn't
even fighting in this scene which just
makes it more horrifying and effective
imagine losing your entire Squad to
someone clasping her hands in some
Temple a couple of miles away like a
looming Horseman of death her presence
in this show is just borderline
terrifying A fitting character for this
list no questions asked
[Music]
rumbling onto our top three now we have
one of the most emotional sacrifices in
the final season of Attack on Titan
hanji sacrificed to save her comrades
from the rumbling
hanji was a brilliant and eccentric
commander of the survey corps who had a
passion for studying and understanding
the Titans she was also a loyal and
courageous leader who always put her
Duty and Friends above her own safety
flying out to meet the Titans hanji
quickly uses up two Thunders Spears to
take down two Titans and seeing that the
group will need more time prepares to
kill using her blades getting close
enough to Kill The Titans with blades
causes hanji to immediately begin
suffering Burns but she manages to enjoy
the heat long enough for the flying boat
to take off before succumbing to her
injuries she used her last moments to
unleash her inner Titan researcher and
slow down the Colossal Titans with her
witty remarks and explosives hanji's
technical abilities in terms of using
the 3D maneuvering gear might not be on
par with Levi nor does she possess
Irwin's military genius but she does
rival them in terms of willpower and
courage one doesn't simply charge
towards their own death without any
doubts and this girl decides to do so
with a smile on her face if there's one
thing an army fears it's a lone
individual who doesn't Buckle or field
yes they're gonna end up taking it down
which is not going down without a fight
taking Colossal Titan after Colossal
Titan with her
next up on the list we have the Shinobi
of iwangakure Gabi Maru the hollow
[Music]
despite the show only airing recently we
actually got a decent amount of action
scenes with the main man himself in the
spotlight of course those scenes
portrayed his ferocity and beasts-like
nature of fighting very well if you
literally stack bodies into a mountain
when you're doing your day job then yeah
I think that deserves a certificate of
approval the best showcase for Gabby
maru's one-man Army potential is his
fight against the prisoners his biggest
concern isn't that he'll be fighting you
but the fact that he finds killing
really bothersome the southern nature
that the fight starts with is so
visceral as he rips and tears multiple
Targets in quick succession he did all
of that while being restricted by the
way a little handicap for the scrubs I
suppose along with his ninpo techniques
this guy is an opponent that you wish
you wouldn't go up against ascetic Blaze
alone is enough to even take care of a
dozen trained Fighters just makes you
wonder what type of badassery this guy
is capable of in the upcoming episodes
good enough
next up we have our favorite blob of
cuteness only in this case he's really
pissed and rightfully so
you know
[Music]
after the massive surprise attack that
was carried out on rimaru settlement he
sets his eyes on Revenge and attempts to
achieve demonhood in an attempt to
revive his lost comrades when the comic
relief character turns silent for a
whole episode then you surely did
something that he didn't like one bit
after the massacre of course rumoru
responded in kind and there just happens
to be a large army parked in his
backyard right for the taking for his
Ascension as he gracefully hovers over
the enemy's army camp he then reigned
death from above as he turned the entire
area into a glorified game of laser tag
with his ability megido he quickly
dispatched the entire army soldiers as
he simply spectated the entire ordeal
from above without a single care for the
lives he's taking and if you consider
the fact that he made an anti-magic area
earlier it just made the slaughter more
hopeless nothing screams one-man Army
more than a good old-fashioned solo Army
white the most terrifying thing in this
whole scenario is the method that
carried out this Slaughter maybe there
isn't some flashy big explosion magic
that just wipes swaths of enemies in an
instant but a precise and accurate ray
of light that's Queen quick sudden and
unsuspecting killing you without you
even noticing seeing as it can easily
Pierce through armor-like butter like
pigs to a slaughterhouse they didn't
even see it coming
and finally our number one pick is David
Martinez from cyberpunk Edge runners
what an unexpected hit in 2022 the anime
showed the many ups and downs in the
life of our boy David David's ability
allows him to move and be faster than
everyone to the point that it looks like
everything was just slowing down for him
the ability comes from military-grade
cyberware that also has the Grim side
effect of David slowly losing his mind
or in Universe turn being cyber
psychosis then I'd approach to type
cyber skeleton to his Arsenal against
the cyborg United States Army and you
have the recipe for the ultimate of one
man army moment equipped with
anti-gravity generators thrusters and
arms that can control magnetic fields
David's tricked into testing out his
death trap when they're ambushed and
cornered by militech agents the
equivalent of the US Army of 2077. every
cyberware put in one's body means the
greater the burden and higher risk for
cyber psychosis so as expected the
craziness raged David uses the hunk of
metal to deliver Mayhem to the soldiers
in just a matter of seconds with the
creative kills ranging from being
crushed to death by gravity or painted
with bullets from your own gun all the
soldiers ever saw on that Battlefield
was a giant blur Before Their Heads
exploded even armored cars and tanks are
no match for this flying metal demon
David slips in and out of psychosis
treading the border of sanity and
becoming a literal Edge runner at this
moment David Martinez is the perfect
Underdog that Rose to the top and went
out with a bang a legend of night City
and that's why he's on top of this list
and that ends this list for the top 10
one-man Army moments of
2020-2023 with three years worth of
great action anime there are bound to be
many that have overlooked let me know in
the comments down below and thanks again
for watching this video